welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Rudy James Rhodes was confirmed
to be a scroll on secret Invasion and
its finale episode finally showed us the
true Roadie wearing a hospital gown with
the true Everett Ross asking the
question we all want to know who wrote
how long have you been in here yeah
Roadie doesn't answer but he does try to
walk in wow he needs some assistance the
hospital gown plus the fact that he's
surprised that he has to struggle
walking suggests that Brody has been a
squirrel since 2016's Captain America
Civil War when his spine was injured
during the airport battle in Germany and
he underwent surgery so the last thing
this really remembers is this
foreign
this would mean that all the events
thereafter in rhodey's Timeline
including Avengers Infinity War Avengers
end game two of the most Monumental
films in MCU history were actually in
the presence of a scroll version of
roadie and if the real Roadie missed all
of it I'm gonna break down every part of
Brody's timeline that has now been
affected by this reveal and what it
really means for the character and for
all the Avengers okay we last saw rodie
in a hospital gown in Civil War in 2016
after the airport battle when he
received an MRI he was conscious then
and he likely still would have been
Roadie at that point but shortly after
this Tony tells Natasha that Brody
suffered an extreme laceration to the
spinal cord which would probably require
some kind of surgery and we don't see
Brody again until the end of the film
when Tony helps him with some physical
therapy 138 138 combat Missions at San
Manuel flown Tony every one of them
could have been my last but I flew I
signed because it was the right thing to
do and yeah this sucks this is uh
is a bad beat now it is possible that
sometime when Tony was distracted
fighting Steve Rogers and Bucky Barnes
and Siberia Roadie would have been
snatched by skrulls now Visions seem to
be holding vigil but you never know you
just get a shape-shifted surgeon in
there a scroll Wanda to maximize a
vision over a bowl of pepper crash and
you could get a new Roadie in Rudy's
speech in Civil War about his 138 combat
Mission seems pretty authentic to
rhodey's character but it could also
have been the scroll rava just learning
a basic stat from Rudy's file and using
that to connect with Tony here the
question would be why in 2016 would any
scroll faction seek to supplant an
Avenger considering all the Scrolls were
probably on team Fury at that point
since Fury was caught by surprise that
Rodeo was a scrolled during secret
Invasion this would mean that some
squirrels went against his wishes in
2016 to meddle with his Affairs and
screw around with the Avengers and
manage to keep that from Nick Fury it
would also mean that these Scrolls had
betrayed Fury years before the snap
perhaps rava could have done this
disubert team Iron Man during the Civil
War conflict to try to derail the
signing of the Segovia Accords which
would have required superhero
registration and theoretically could
have made it harder for the squirrels to
stay hidden if that was the plan though
it failed the sokovia Accords became law
for several years staying in effect at
least until the events of She-Hulk when
Matt Murdoch revealed that sokovia
courts had been repealed for the next
few times we see Rody in the MCU he's
walking around with these stark-built
leg braces in Infinity War he references
the Civil War Revenge to Thaddeus Ross
if it weren't for those Accords vision
would have been right here
I remember your signature on those
papers colonel
that's right
and I'm pretty sure I paid for that you
have second thoughts not anymore Brody
refuses to arrest cap and the others and
hangs up on the hollow call with Ross
stain will get court-martialed and we
learned that Bruce had been staying with
Rudy in the compound and Bruce's
connection with Roadie in this movie
could be an important clue especially if
Brody were a scroll during this period
because in She-Hulk it was a scroll
spaceship that picked up Bruce Banner
and took him back to pick up his son's
scar rava could have been Bruce's scroll
connection Rudy would go on to join the
Avengers in the battle against stannis's
outriders in wakanda and he was there at
the moment that thanos's snap when he
was looking for Sam Wilson in an
Avengers end game Rudy joined the
Avengers at the top of that movie and
snaps at Carol Danvers hey new girl
everybody in this room is about that
Superhero life and if you don't mind my
asking where the hell have you been all
this time there are a lot of other
planets in the universe
and unfortunately they didn't have you
guys remember the squirrels at this
point in time might have had a
particular ire toward Carol Danvers and
Nick Fury for leaving them behind on
Earth without a new home there's also
this moment when rocket asks who hair
hasn't been to space
what yeah Roadie is the last to raise
his hand I mean we just have to note
that when these scenes were written and
shot neither Don Cheadle nor Marcus and
mcpeely or the Russo Brothers intended
Brody to be a scroll for these moments
we're just really looking back at all of
rodi's timeline for ways that this
reveal could make sense for example five
years later during The Avengers
conference call Roadie alerts Natasha
that Clint Barton slaughtered a bunch of
cartel guys and there was a little
moment before he brought this up where
Carol Danvers tells him good luck as if
Rhodey had confided in Carol as to
whether or not he should mention it to
Nat if you've ever wanted to transform
your spare time into something awesome
you can put on your shelf then you
should check out the Optimus Prime
replica kit from fan home fan home is a
brand dedicated to developing unique
Collections and build up models from
Brands like Hasbro Marvel and Star Wars
a fan home subscription gets you
magazines loaded with trivia and stories
about your favorite fandom but also
everything you need to build your very
own Optimus Prime fan homes Optimus
Prime replica is awesome it's a highly
detailed articulated 23 inch tall badass
truck robot made of die cast metal and
ABS plastic it comes with weapons it has
led that make its eyes light up and yeah
it would be overwhelming and stressful
to try to build this all at once but
that's what's so great about fan home
every month you get new Parts Plus
instructions on how to put everything
together so you can build your model up
bit by bit on top of that you'll also
get Transformer swag including a
backpack t-shirt keyring mug and posters
a fan home subscription is the perfect
way to make your collection stand out to
get started just click the link in the
description below and remember Avengers
end game is also where Roadie proposes
this why don't we just find baby Thanos
you know and
first of all that's horrible it's Thanos
and secondly time doesn't work that way
Rudy also lists an impressive number of
time travel movies Star Trek Terminator
time cop Time After Time Quantum Leap
Wrinkle in Time Somewhere in Time Hot
Tub Time Machine Bill and Ted's
Excellent Adventure and then on the Time
Heist Brody backhands and knocks out
Peter Quilla morax so that he can grab
the Power Stone and then after thanos's
forces arrive to the president he joins
the other Avengers in the Battle of
Earth Roadie is the first one at Tony
Stark's side as Tony dies and we later
see Rhody joining the family for Tony's
goodbye recording and then on the dock
during the funeral crying throughout all
of this Roadie and happy Hogan hug and I
recently pointed out how they actually
say something to each other we don't
hear it but you can do some lip reading
and I thought Roadie's line might end in
the word home now I'm wondering if he
said the word unbelievable let me know
what you think he's saying here so yes
as we've pointed out before the last
time we see Roadie before the secret
evasion series it's in the Falcon the
Winter Soldier when he tells Sam Wilson
well it's a crazy place right now people
are well nobody's stable allies are now
enemies alliances are all
torn apart the world's broken
everybody's just looking for somebody to
fix it and for a while I wondered if
Marvel might never ret Khan a
conversation between two black Avengers
but rava as Roadie spoke way more about
being a black person in secret Invasion
episodes despite being a green scroll
pretending to be a black man so clearly
Marvel isn't Beyond doing this ah look
Rudy is a man of a certain age and he
could have donned a hospital gown for
any routine colonoscopy at any point
after Avengers end game I just think
that his struggles to walk and his
surprise to that fact is a big tell that
the swap happened during Civil War
before Roadie knew that he had some
spinal nerve damage which would mean if
this is the case sadly that this Roadie
does not know that Tony Stark is dead
and if that was secret invasion's intent
with this it is criminal that this
series didn't show us rhodey's reaction
to that so will we have to wait until
armor Wars for Roadie to react to Tony
Stark's death or react to the world
having dusted for five years to who
Thanos is that wakanda is a thing also
did Doctor Strange's memory wipe spell
in no way home not affect Roadie and
does Roadie still know that Peter Parker
is Spider-Man if Marvel is saying that
Don Cheadle has been a scroll since
2016. I get why a lot of us would feel
really weird about that I think one way
they could have gotten around it what I
would have loved to see is more
characterization of the character of
rava in secret Invasion instead of
making her an who talks down to
everyone and then just dies like if
Rhodey was a scroll since Civil War I
want to know why that swap was made in
2016. I want some context on how that
squirrel felt assimilating with the
memories and personality of her human
host and possibly feeling a genuine
fondness for her fellow Avengers and hey
maybe actually crying sincere tears upon
losing a friend that's what I was most
interested in earlier in the secret of
Asian season when the squirrels talked
about now take his mind and dogmatically
had to wear the skin of their human
captors what does that do dude was
scroll like graphic and Vara talked
about the humans they took and who those
people were but not really how it felt
to carry their memories inside of their
own heads with their own memories so the
result is instead of feeling like we
gained new interesting context instead
we just kind of lost a history that we
thought we always had I don't know we'll
see what Marvel Studios does about this
but I want to know your thoughts in the
comments below subscribe to all three
channels in the new rockstars Network
follow me on all social platforms at
eavos follow new rockstars And subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis for
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]